hey everyone welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for honor again and
we have some information to talk about
today we have a road map some next-gen
details for the new
upcoming consoles a new esports dominion
series and some content of the week so
as always
like to be if you do enjoy subscribe if
you're new let's get started with
today's video
so first up is the content of the week
you're going to be getting an effect and
a battle outfit this week called
medicinal transcendence and medicinal
dreams they look pretty cool
personally i'm probably going to be
using the effect more than the battle
outfit but once again if you want to get
this you definitely can
next up is the october road map now to
spare you some of the more
boring details of the arcade quest
coming every weekend so
for the more important details there is
a double xp weekend on the 16th to the
19th
on the 22nd is a huge day with twitch
drops a new title update
extra loot and new content of the week
and judging by the fact that the image
is very large on the map
it seems important and lastly on the
24th we have the dominion series esports
tournament which like i said we will get
to
soon next up is the biggest kind of
section of the video and that is
next-gen details
for honor is confirmed to be on next-gen
and will actually be receiving graphical
enhancements at launch
lots of the improved details as you're
seeing on screen all of those which will
be included
and at the bottom it says 4k resolution
if you have a ps5 or series x
or it's going to be 1080p on the series
s and obviously the current xbox one
that i have can run the game at 1080p as
well
but the series s has the same resolution
as the xbox one
but with those other added details water
improvement shadow improvement so at the
end of the day
it is still an upgrade if you get the
series s and play for honor
it's backwards compatible as well so
there's no need to purchase a new
edition of the game just so you can play
on the next gen consoles
and some big news for the console
players 60 fps will be coming to console
but not at launch
they do plan to shoot for an early
december launch which is roughly a month
after the new consoles launch in
november
and roughly the start of the new season
year four season four
so look for 60 fps on console around
there to summarize all this if you're a
console player and looking to play for
honor on the next gen consoles
just get the respective console that you
play on if you're a playstation player
you need to get your ps5 if you're an
xbox player get the series s
or the series x and that is all you keep
the regular edition of your for honor
game whether that be a physical disc
or a digital version like i have and
then all you have to do is just play the
game
so just get the new console and play the
game and you'll get all the upgrades
it doesn't you don't need to cost
anything else for another upgrade of the
game or
any other [ __ ] like that just pay
your 500 some 200 300 something dollars
for the new console
then you're good to go and then lastly
we have the dominion series
for this basically it is a competition
or esports event
as you can tell by the graphic that is
on screen this is going to be the
bracket of what's happening
hopefully this bracket explains it a lot
better than i'm going to be kind of
commentating with it
for the ladder of competition there is
the poles at the very top which is
available to everyone
one of them actually starting roughly at
the same time of this month
winners qualify and those winners then
go to qualifiers
then the qualifiers go and then the top
two teams
go to the finale qualifiers with the
third and fourth going to the lcq
qualifiers the winner of the first two
teams faces the winner of the lcq
like i said hopefully the guide provided
on screen is a lot more making sense in
your head than
me speaking so let's hope that works out
you can go to battlefied.com
dominion series if you want to learn all
the details required to play
and the prize pool is around 35 000 so a
nice chunk of change for
winning this and remember it does say
dominion series so
make sure to get a team going and those
are all the details of the stream
not too much stuff today it was a pretty
short stream but
some really interesting details for
next-gen that were definitely very
important and
60 fps coming to console is something
the console players have been talking
about
since day one of the game but yeah
that's going to be the end of the video
today guys hope you guys did enjoy
like to be if you did subscribe if
you're new and as always peace out
i'll see you in another video probably
going to be talking about the new title
update
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
hmm you